you guys ready to talk about the rate
you know I'm excited to watch the raid I
mean talk about it I'll watch it again
brother hey guys Ryan right here and I'm
Jerry Sally not here welcome to reasons
to see where we give you reasons to Z
the rain not know not burned oh yeah I
guess they took that off for America so
let's hang out alright guys so we saw
the raid - electric Boogaloo yeah ray -
bar and all Behrend all it means thugs
or tough guys or [ __ ] who want
to kick some ass I don't know a buncha
guys are so mean - definition sorry
these guys complain about me being loud
but it is [ __ ] incredible there's a
lot more story in it there's a lot more
story in it Sally Gary huh there's more
story in this one you guys really need
to go see an ENT I kind of thought it
like the dark night of how a transition
from Batman Begins because this one it
feels like a total crime thriller yeah
it's more of an insolvent the whole time
it's a crime epic yeah it's a crime epic
I mean this movie is almost the opposite
cuz the first one is like very immediate
it's just what's going on right now and
this movie they obviously have a bigger
budget more toys to play with is like
much more intricate and there's a lot of
cutting back and forth between various
things going on first one was more just
like let's put out a kick-ass action
film this one was very like last season
of Breaking Bad asked it was really
intense you really had to pay attention
to the name so much meth in it - gosh oh
my god I'm incredible amounts of meth
and that's why they moved the way they
did they explain why they're able to
move like that finally cool weed awful
what Sally said thinking about the
simplicity of the first one that's why I
think like this is not to say part 2
isn't entertaining because it certainly
is but part 1 I thought had a more
natural sense of fun to it only because
it's much more simple it's more straight
to the point
it's lean you know yes I do like the
fact that it did seem like a whole other
movie it did have a couple of things in
it that was a little confusing but it
didn't really take away from it it got a
really bad yeah
you would think it'll be easier because
they're reading subtitles the whole time
no it's kind of confusing sometimes one
part of it too is like you're trying to
read but you're also trying to sort of
drink in one frame and yeah and also
like because these movies are so
artistic in the way that each shot is
done so not only are you reading the
subtitles and trying to remember the
names but you're also like trying to pay
attention to these shots because they're
all yeah oh each shot is like perfectly
a frame especially in the theatre it's
amazing like the first shot you just see
this huge like feel you open here yeah
and then in the very corner do you see
like these cars pull up and it's like at
a scene from a [ __ ] like well you
know we're about to kill someone in the
desert even before that it just starts
like the first action is just little
puffs of smoke that come up you know you
know that's actually the most effective
thing in my opinion because you're so
focused on this little tiny bit that
when it cuts to the actual part it's
just like boom and you're really
surprised yeah the thing that really got
me which I just moved him in the car was
the shot of the leaf it just was showing
like leaves and I was like why do they
keep showing this and then all of a
sudden you see blood splatter and it
just goes those shots just make the film
though it's a really well shot movie
them all around and I mean by its
beautiful the first ones well shot but
it's like there's a lot of stuff that's
really symmetrical and picturesque but
then there are these things where
there's a mud fight oh that was great
that scene is feels like it's all being
shot in these really long takes and it's
like handheld on those the technical
prowess and how they were able to
capture all these things over such long
shots in camera like they must have been
a choreograph everything yeah and I
tried finding continuity issues with
this film and I did oh the editing is
really it was really really an editing
throughout man shouldn't show even
comment on the music I mean like we
shall it so perfect that you don't even
you know want something flows so well in
the movie you don't even notice it but
then you're like damn actually that was
pretty badass music sound sounded music
both play a huge part in this movie what
I really like too was the just don't
roll the setup of the characters because
you're way more emotionally invest at
this time
I like those undercover stories where
they get so involved in it that you know
are they becoming a criminal it what's
weird it says they know there's a time
Rome like oh yeah traumas in this movie
because he's kind of gone for a walk
tomorrow to the belt it does come back
to him and it's totally worth it but the
villains I thought were really [ __ ]
good
like really good really nice getting
invested in these villains cuz then at
one point I was kind of felling rooting
for but the Sun what was his name the
Sun of the basically the guy the guy
that Rama got out of jail like he saved
his life in jail I really just loved his
character even though he was a villain
at one point I was kind of rooting for
him and Rama to kind of join forces both
be good but that didn't happen well it's
that thing where you start to wonder
like who who is on the better side of
things right now is that you know these
crime organizations is it the police are
the people I'm working for crooked oh it
was constantly changing and that's what
I like is it wasn't just like one person
the one hour time that was a bad guy and
oh they knew exactly what to introduce
another bad guy it's like when they
finally show the girl from the trailer
who's like kicking those guys asses on
the train I was like oh yeah I forgot
about this character because she comes
in at the right exact moment like so
late into the ground I guess the girl
that she's badass I call her hammer girl
she is [ __ ] awesome dude shreya the
the credits call her hammer curls that
is god her name is like Alisha or
something and then in parenthesis it
just says hammer girl yeah she was
[ __ ] awesome jealous of the actress
who played that's such an awesome role
to have one that's it that's another
thing that makes the second one a much
bigger and more expansive than the first
one is that there are a lot more
colorful characters and a lot more sort
of eccentric characters in this movie
and you know definitely the villains are
the first ones more about the immediate
thing that's happening yeah whereas this
one is it's exploring like the
underworld at this point and it's really
[ __ ] me Oh even like [ __ ] baseball
guy he was great too I was like this
guy's bad it's like the villains are bad
looks like just a bum who's due just got
off the couch eating potato
like playing video games just walking
around with this baseball bat my huge
like and that sort of leads into just
the action generally is so creative and
that's part of what makes first movies
so good is that there are so many
different kinds of fights and this movie
even builds on that words like different
weapons different spaces that they're
fighting in different amounts of people
there's a car chase that feels more like
a list more like a martial arts fight
scene than a car chase they caked fast
and furious as ass without one cause she
said that loudest [ __ ] Oh God a little
Hollywood theater I would have been like
cool at Arclight cinemas were they
really encourage you to shut your mouth
she's like okay this movie has a lot of
attention to detail that I love and at
one point this Indonesian mob family and
then this Japanese my family are talking
and they talk in English to each other
because it's a common language and Sally
decided to shout out Oh English she was
so excited just to hear that people were
read and it was so perfect that they
even did that because as you said like a
lot of Japanese people see English
because of the whole business they mean
they do a lot of business of America
that's a common limit what I was also
thinking though is that a flaw huge flaw
in American films is that whenever
someone is foreign automatically they
just they're British yeah they're
British unless you can no wait wait yeah
like unless they're Asian or black they
can't pee yeah look it's like a comic
book because every character is has so
much depth to them even if you don't
spend too much amount of time with them
the father of the Indonesian crime
family am i boring you Sally no I know
what's happening dude we watch two
three-hour movies in like two days I'm
so tired
yeah his father he was a great character
too because he was like scary but he was
very authentic he wasn't employing evil
god I think it was art from know yeah I
mean he's actually your kind of even
though he's a criminal you're kind of on
board with his medicine it's like as a
criminal he's running this in probably
the best way possible
absolutely as far as the action goes
like everyone knows the actions gonna be
[ __ ] amazing compared to the first
one the first one feels like it might
have more action and it maybe does so it
does um this movie is twice as long as
the first one but there's also like a
look like the first hours and primarily
dialogue that's true I mean like I can
understand where the balance of it may
have felt like this one had didn't have
as much but then towards the end it's
just like constant cause I can't like do
you have a minute fight scene here's
what I gotta say about the action the
first one once the action kicks in it
just kicks in and then it's just for
like 90 minutes yeah and this one the
action scenes are very much spread out
the movie has such a build to it like
like this low no yeah because if it
makes it more emotional when the fight
scenes come in and when it got through
the [ __ ] finale when rama's like it's
answer me one question
yeah is my family safe he's like okay
because some shits about to go down [ __ ]
goes down the crazy thing is the
violence in the first one a lot of time
I felt like just a fun action but
violent film then this one the violence
felt like this is violence everything
was on the line I was like please don't
get cut yeah I will cry well cuz you
know in the limited nature of the first
one it's like you've got soldiers with
guns and then attack people backing him
up in the first one this one yeah pretty
much alone but you have all these
soldiers with guns and then versus you
know people living in a tenement with
just whatever's around maybe a machete
this movie is like you're dealing with
various criminals from all over and so
the range of weaponry is far wider and
they really take advantage of one thing
I do have to say though can anyone
explain to me like the last real fight
scene he had with that guy with the the
- the claws usually have like the claw
things towards the end of that he like
ripped Rama's tendons right where his
the back of his knee is but for the rest
of the fight scene he didn't really limp
at all and it's like and he was like
well yeah because it's need adrenaline
but but I understand you get shot I
didn't have to wonder about it if you
actually sever something were you and
because you can't but there's a
difference between your leg not working
yeah you and I'm like okay I understand
if you get shot like somewhere yes
we'll still keep running until you run
out of blood then you pass out but with
something gripping also your tendons
ripping and stuff like you can't there's
no justification for the dog that you
will you won't be able to use that way
will you taking up with if you guys
suspend disbelief you will not make it
10 minutes and in this movie but but you
got to point rounds like I understand
when he did that no one's still kept
fighting I was like they could have just
ended it when that happened ok I'm
actually with you on it it's like there
is a certain point where you do in your
head sort of acknowledge ok it wouldn't
be steady however I don't care because
I'm not saying it was a fault or
whatever but I'm just saying it was a
little much if that's the only thing
wrong with this movie I mean it's still
[ __ ]
[Music]